i'm screaming from the rooftop saying
you might be cynical you might think you
don't understand it you might think
you can't afford to play in this
but you have to listen because this is
the opportunity every single rich person
understands how to benefit from the
system
hold assets not a currency if you hold a
thousand bitcoin
you hold 1 000 of a possible 21 million
forever right you have a guaranteed
fraction of the total money supply
wanna be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's evan carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know you've got something more
inside you too you have michael jordan
level genius at something so today let's
live your best believe life and learn
why bitcoin will always crush the other
investments
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with idea number
one don't hold the dollar with anthony
pompliano if i denominate my life in
dollars and let's say i buy a loaf of
bread today it's two dollars five or ten
years from now that loaf of bread may
cost me three four five dollars
depending on the rate of inflation
if i denominate my life in bitcoin and
today let's say that it cost me one
bitcoin for a loaf of bread in the
future it will cost me less than one
bitcoin so it'll actually become cheaper
for me to buy because every asset when
you think of price
it's denominated in a currency so a
stock right when i when i ask you what
is amazon's stock price you're telling
me one amazon share over how many u.s
dollars and that's how we get to the
actual value and so when you start to
think about that
look at the stock market the stock
market from 1971 to today is up and to
the right it's a perfect 45 degree angle
oh god i know you're about to say when
you denominate it in gold it's down
that's it says 1971. if you denominated
in bitcoin since 2009 uh 2010 it has
crashed aggressively bitcoin has been
the best performing asset but that's
because it's denominated in dollars and
so ultimately what we're watching is
we're watching an entire generation of
people wake up to this fiat currency
kind of fiasco
and there's a famous uh i think it's
henry ford quote where he said you know
if people understood how money worked
there would be riots in the street
before morning
and it's simply against respect to that
education gap and so the 55 of people
hold investable assets whether they
understand why or not they're actually
benefiting from this
and so it's important to remember that i
don't think there are um
nefarious or malicious intentions or you
know let's screw people at the bottom of
the totem pole in fact sometimes it's
actually the exact opposite
but the system is working as designed
it's a feature not a bug and the reason
why that's important to understand is
because
the system is not going to change right
you and i are not going to be able to
convince anybody to do anything
different they're going to do what
they're going to do because that's the
way the system is built
but what you can do is you can change
the way that you're positioned so you
have a choice i can either suffer at the
hands of this system
or i can flip around the other side
table and i can benefit from the system
every single rich person understands how
to benefit from the system
hold assets not a currency don't hold
the dollar instead hold the assets idea
number two analyze all options with gary
vaynerchuk you first heard about bitcoin
didn't really get it or it didn't really
click then it was ethereum now i have to
ask do you think of yourself as an
ethereum
i might say maxi that's a term in the
industry ethereum maximalists they say
forget bitcoin all the potential for
business applications is ethereum or
have you now gone back and do you also
own bitcoin i bought bitcoin back then
so that did really well um
uh no i'm a i'm a big believer in and
i'm i think the worst one of the worst
characteristics in the crypto landscape
right now
is people
buying things and then all of their
opinions are grounded in their own
self-financial interests that's how you
have a bad reputation that's how you are
not historically correct this is going
to be a game of and i back to
december how i use it i can't wait to go
very deep into solana this december
holiday season to understand what i
think in comparison to immutable x and
layer two versus eth mainnet
no i think it's insane to think this is
a zero-sum game i think that there will
be many platforms probably i have a much
better understanding of the human
psychology around nfts than i do around
the financial aspect of coins so i don't
as you probably know because i know you
watch the space carefully i don't talk a
lot about bitcoin or the alternative
currencies because i really don't
understand
that game i very much understand why
people wear nike's rolexes by
mercedes-benz communication human
behavior and that's why i'm so
very focused on nfts because i think
they represent social communication in a
way that other things come natural to me
and that's where my focus is well and
really now crypto punk's arguably
becoming some might say board apes i
mean pick your collection
the example of those highest
you know tier in the nft world but it's
going to keep changing i mean yeah and i
think some like my bet is that what i
bet on because i bought a bunch of
crypto punks and i believe it even more
now watching this year play out some
things will be
tiffany's
like locked and loaded for hundreds of
years x copy
the artist shows all the nuances of
potentially becoming a warhol or a
banksy or a pollock
um so somebody's gonna win that game
board ape v friends cool cats i think a
lot of those brands are gonna play the
brand game
so supreme is hot for seven years but
it's hard to be hot for 50 years
right so there's gonna be a classics and
there's gonna be the hop brand and
there's a lot to think through
um and i'm spending a lot of time on it
idea number three take the opportunity
with robert paul the internet
from 1990 to 2000 grew at 63 percent a
year
that was the fastest adoption of any
technology in all recorded history prior
to that
mobile phones
was the other one
but what happens is the internet
technology and the mobile phone
technology allows for these
networks to be built
and once that network's in place it's
faster to build the net next network so
in india for example they've just
basically given out free data to every
mobile phone in india so guess what
uh data usage is the highest in the
world
and so their internet scaling becomes
faster
so this so the internet was huge as we
all know and it remains huge so at 63 a
year it then flattened out over time as
more and more people got adopted
so at 1997 it was growing at 63 a year
and it was 140 million users of the
internet
in 2021 there are 140 million crypto
users
and it's growing at 113 percent a year
which is double the speed now this is
where humans struggle
linear numbers and exponential numbers
because it's exponential
it means that growing at 113 a year
we're going to go from 140 million
people to a billion people by 2024.
i mean so
so
so when you go back
and what you how are you introduced all
of this so if you know
that something is being adopted at this
speed and it's a networking of money
at its core
and you can buy an infinitesimal
fraction of it so everybody can buy 10
of their net worth
then everybody who takes this
opportunity will probably have the
biggest opportunity
in history
to make money i did a piece that's
probably the most viewed piece i've ever
done on youtube it's like i don't know
two million two or three million views
called the retirement crisis
and it resonated because i i kind of
showed how people people haven't seen it
check it out on youtube it's well worth
your time and it's a long time ago it
predicts a lot of what's going on now
and um
the point being is that there's a bunch
of retirees the baby boomers and they've
kind of screwed it all up because
they've got all the debt
um they've got too much equity exposure
it's really hard for them to retire this
is why the federal reserve don't like
equities going down because you've got
this richest group on earth who are kind
of stuck
they never got enough money to retire on
but i want to look through the eyes of
the millennials
so they are 32 years old
at the same age their parents at 32 the
baby boomers had all-time cheap
valuations of equities all-time cheap
bonds all-time cheap credit all-time
cheap property
right so they couldn't help but make
money they kind of screwed it up because
they actually ended up going into debt
as well
but they couldn't help but make money so
then the millennials had the opposite
all-time record valuations equities
all-time record valuation for bonds
all-time record credit all-time record
highs in property so i'm like these guys
are screwed unless something else comes
along and that thing is crypto
because the future expected return of
crypto it's been growing at 213 a year
in returns i that's how much it makes
even though it's very volatile sometimes
it's down 70 percent
over time you're making 213 a year
it has grown as an asset it's gone up i
think it's 2 million percent since
inception no other asset in all recorded
history has ever done this and we
haven't even started i still think
there's probably another 100 x from here
not even the baby boomers got given that
the s p didn't go up 100 x since 1980.
so
this is the magnitude of what's there so
i'm screaming from the rooftop saying
you might be cynical you might think you
don't understand it you might think
you can't afford to play in this
but you have to listen because this is
the opportunity you can't come back to
me in 10 years time and say well we
missed all of that all the rich people
got richer no you i everybody else is
saying now is your time don't be
irresponsible you know dollar cost
average do all the right things but here
is your opportunity
this is the biggest opportunity i've
ever seen and i'm going to take
advantage of it and so should everybody
else this is not rich or poor this is an
every person opportunity and we've never
had this before ever
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there idea number four see it as an
asset with michael saylor because people
call it a cryptocurrency
then it lends itself to a shallow
criticism that it's not good as a
currency because the central banks will
ban it and because the tax treatment is
poor and because the transaction rate is
low
but again those are all red herrings
it's not a currency nor does it need to
be a currency right any anybody
thinking about it for even a few seconds
realizes that
if there's a taxable event every time i
transfer it to you
it can't be a currency so it's it's so
no it's not a currency it's an asset
and if you think of it as an asset
it's very helpful because then you
realize it's not competing with the
dollar and the euro it's competing with
gold and silver
it's competing with bearer instruments
uh
and and to a certain degree
it's competing with bonds as a store of
value
and it's competing with
etfs like the s p 500 index as a store
of value
and once you understand it that way
then you're not so afraid anymore
because you understand the regulatory
framework that comes to bitcoin is the
same regulatory framework that comes to
gold silver and s p 500 indexes
it's just know your customer anti-money
laundering regulations
and if you're if you're afraid to buy
bitcoin because you're afraid of
regulation
you shouldn't be
because if it is regulated para pursue
or at parity with these other assets
it will create
it'll create a avalanche of
institutional money flow into the asset
class
because it'll simply normalize the
treatment in the western world the irs
in 2014
deemed it to be property right
property it means that it means that
when you transfer it you owe a capital
gains tax so there is like zero chance
the irs is going to reverse that it is
property it's not a currency idea number
five hold inviolable property with
robert breedlove bitcoin
is the first permanent implementation of
this principle we've been refining
throughout human history
of inviolable property
it actually cannot be violated in any
way
no one can produce more than 21 million
bitcoin so it's
and i've argued this in some of my
writing that although it's an invention
we've actually discovered something with
bitcoin we've discovered
absolute scarcity for money so if we're
back to those five properties of money
in terms of scarcity bitcoin is absolute
it's not relative right it doesn't
change we know with
you know
nothing's um
people argue with me about this it's not
absolute everything's probabilistic true
uh bitcoin has proven itself over 13
years of flawless operation that it does
two things essentially perfectly
are turn out a block on
one block of transactions on average
every 10 minutes and adhere to a supply
cap of 21 million
so it's the first fixed supply money
there has ever been
and i don't think you can recreate that
because by definition
money is a centripetal network effect so
it we tend towards one so for the same
reasons we had one analog gold we're
likely only to have one digital gold
this
so your property rights cannot be
violated by inflation because no one can
change the supply cap if you hold a
thousand bitcoin
you hold one thousand of a possible 21
million forever right you have a
guaranteed fraction of the total money
supply
you cannot get that level of assurance
with any other asset in the world
full stop doesn't exist even with gold
you can hold all the physical gold you
want
you're still not immune to
uh some technological breakthrough we
figured out figured out how to produce
gold in the lab very cheaply we mine an
asteroid we mine the ocean floor we find
a new south american bonanza whatever
you're not immune to any of that but
with bitcoin
and again it's a bit of a bet because
it's only 13 years in but it's done
these things perfectly so far
if it continues to do what it's been
doing for 13 years you have a guaranteed
fraction of total money supply so you
have an inviolable
property right idea number six invest
now with robert kiyosaki in december you
call that bitcoin will hit 50k in early
2021
and you were correct you even tweeted it
let's read that tweet glad i bought
bitcoin next stop 50k wall of
institutional money coming 2021
buy below 20k if you missed bitcoin by
silver silver set to move due to aoc's
green new deal america in trouble future
bright for gold silver bitcoin and
entrepreneurs all right let's break down
that advice there robert you said buy
below 20k if you missed it by silver
okay so now that bitcoin has hit a
record high of over 61k
and is now in the high 50k range
is it too late to get into bitcoin where
do you see it going that's a very good
question because it's always the entry
point
like i bought bitcoin at 9 000 and i
thought i was being fleeced
but the reason i bought it at nine was
because
uh kovitz shut down the world economy
so i thought it was pretty when they
started printing so i bought bitcoin at
nine i wish i bought it at 10 cents like
a lot of people did
but now i look like a genius because
today is around 55 000. this is uh what
april
2021
and i think it's going to go to
1.2 million
in five more years and idea number seven
the last one before some very special
bonus clips is save in the bank with
kathy wood what is the long-term play
when it comes to something like
cryptocurrencies in bitcoin so bitcoin
specifically um
we we got involved when it was a six
billion dollar market cap and here's art
laffer again in
in my life and in ark's life
um
it was a six billion dollar cap then now
it's over a trillion which is but we
were asking the question this was 2015.
could bitcoin serve the three rolls of
money and we came to the conclusion that
it was possible art laffer collaborated
he tore our original paper up and as we
were going through it
he said
this is the first
this is the rules based
monetary system i've been waiting for
since
we left the gold exchange standard 71
1971 right and i said to him oh
how big could this be
and he said
well how big is the u.s monetary base
and back then remember this is six
billion dollar cap back then it was a
four and a half trillion dollar monetary
base today we're at eight and a half
trillion uh and and bitcoins at one
trillion and that's uh that's just one
of its roles one of its roles i think
the most fascinating thing that's
happening is in el salvador have you
heard they deemed bitcoin the president
who tweets every day
deemed bitcoin
legal tender and there's a bloomberg
quiz question okay i do it every week
okay
and sent a chivo wallet uh to every
everyone uh in the population eligible
so four million
three million it had 30 dollars worth of
bitcoin in it 3 million have to have
downloaded it only 1.2 million in that
country uh have a banking relationship
so this is the new bank digital wallets
and it's going to be true in this
country it's going to be true around the
world
i see the blockchain as something that
is going to change the world and that as
a business owner i really better
understand that and then as i came to
understand it i realized that it plugged
in perfectly with the kind of things
that i need to do in order to build the
next disney so i had to learn about this
technology now whenever you're learning
about a technology you start with a
lexicon so you're going to fumble around
so you're going to go and you're going
to type into youtube whatever word you
know cryptocurrency bitcoin ethereum
nfts whatever is that starting point
that you're at
then as you get in you're going to begin
to encounter the language so you want to
start learning the terms the next thing
is that you're going to start to
figure out who the different players are
in the space and then once you figure
out who the players are you're going to
go deep down the rabbit hole of actually
gaining that expertise okay so it starts
with words lexicon then it goes to
influencers and then finally it goes to
the actual true understanding that's
going to come over time
and you need to start using it now
the fastest way to learn about
cryptocurrency is to go invest in some
again
this is not financial advice and if i
haven't already said this let me tell
you when it comes to cryptocurrency
which is an extremely volatile asset the
only thing more volatile than
cryptocurrency is nfts nfts are like the
king of volatility of lack of uh
liquidity right you can get your money
tied up in an nft and never be able to
get it out so you need to be very
thoughtful
that the utility of that thing is worth
the money that you're paying for it okay
that's incredibly important all right so
the fastest way to learn about
cryptocurrency is to go buy some but
you're not going to invest any money
that you can't afford to lose okay say
that again you're not going to invest
any money that you can't afford to lose
the first thing i would do and did is go
to coinbase it's very easy it's one of
many there are many that you can do but
speaking from experience i went to
coinbase it was very easy for me to set
up an account there's something called
kyc which stands for know your customer
so they're going to ask it's anti-money
laundering they're going to ask you a
lot of questions they're probably going
to make you send in if i remember right
you have to photocopy both sides of your
driver's license and send that in
they're going to encourage you to
connect your bank account there are
other ways that you can do it i ended up
treating like an ach wire so i wasn't in
the beginning days i was not comfortable
connecting my bank account and so
i gave them my routing number and my
account number
so that i could ach money back and forth
so
follow your comfort level only do what
you understand and only do what you're
comfortable with once you have a
coinbase account then you can trade your
fiat currency just your us dollars
for
the cryptocurrency of your choice again
only invest in the ones that you
understand and believe have utility for
me i think the very first thing that i
bought was bitcoin the next thing that i
bought was
ethereum and then the third thing that i
bought again this is all based on my
understanding of the technology was
something called chain link
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so as a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want proof that bitcoin will become even
more valuable check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll love it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there if you pull in your time frame to
less than a year less than 12 months and
you and you consider you know regulatory
uncertainty and market liquidity crisis
like just about anything can happen